find the product four times negative
five times negative seven point five so
we're just multiplying three numbers
right here some are positive some are
negative we could actually do this in
any order but let's just go left to
right so let's start with the four times
the negative five and then we'll
multiply whatever we get there times
negative seven point five so let's just
rewrite the problem so we have four
times negative five times negative seven
point five I really don't have to write
that dot there if you just have four and
then a print in parenthesis in negative
five that means four times negative five
now the first thing you need to realize
is that a positive times well a positive
times a positive is obviously a positive
a positive times a negative or a
negative times a positive when you have
different signs you're going to end up
with a negative if you have same signs
so even if you have a negative times a
negative you're going to have a positive
as well so let's just work that out in
this problem so we have four times
negative five four times five would be
twenty let me do this in a different
color so four times five would be 20 we
have a positive times a negative so it's
going to be a negative different signs
mean we're going to have a negative so
it becomes negative 20 times negative
seven point five so let's figure out
what that is we have to multiply 20
times 7.5 we could do that out here so
7.5 times 20 zero times five is zero
zero times seven is zero put a zero here
because we're obviously not going to
multiply by two we're actually
multiplying by 20 so 2 times 5 is 10 2
times 7 is 14 plus 1 is 15 and we get a
0 we get a 0 we get a 5 I'm just adding
here either one and then you count the
numbers you have behind the decimal
point we only have one digit behind the
decimal point in both numbers so you
only go one digit behind the decimal
point in our product so the answer here
is 150 so this is equal to 150 and now
we just have to think about is it going
to be positive or negative we have a
negative times a negative they are the
same sign so it's going to result
in a positive number so our final answer
is 150 and if we actually wanted to keep
the precision here we could write 150
point zero